ce qu'on vise là c'est de recruter 10000
personnes le 27 mai 2020 alors que le
réseau des CHSLD crack de partout
François Legault annonce la formation
accélérée de 10.000 préposés au
bénéficiaire la veille les consultants
de l'affirme américaine McKenzie
recommandait justement d'accélérer la
formation et les embauches en CHSLD
malgré tout François Lego maintient que
la formation accélérée des préposés aux
bénéficiaires c'était bien son idée
totalement totalement puis j'en suis
fier Radio-Canada a mis la main sur des
échanges courriels entre la firme privée
et la haute fonction publique mckinzie
conseillait notamment le directeur de la
campagne de vaccination Daniel Paris
reçoit un courriel d'un associé du
cabinet conseil McKenzie le 14 décembre
2020 bravo pour cette première journée
qui se déroule bien voici mes notes sur
les suivis action responsables délais le
29 avril 2020 l'administratrice d'État
au ministère de la santé Dominique
Savoie réclame l'aide de la firme
externe pour prendre une décision
cruciale afin écrit-elle d’établir un
bon niveau de réserve pour les deux
prochaines années dans nos achats et
stocks pour nos équipements prioritaires
masques et blues le recours à McKenzie
était justifié explique le chef de la
CAQ en bout de ligne c'est à moi puis
mon équipe qui prenait décision mais je
pense que les recommandations qu'on a eu
entre autres de mécanis nous ont aidé à
sauver des vies mais ce n'est pas la vie
de ces adversaires pendant qu'il y avait
du monde sur le terrain qui demandait à
être écouté François Legault a préféré
écouter des consultants privés d'une
firme multinationale il aime gouverner
seul il aime gouverner sans qu'on le
critique il aime gouverner sans partager
l'information semble avoir joué un rôle
très important dans la gestion de crise
politique François Legault nous
présentait ça comme les décisions du
gouvernement alors qu'il semble y avoir
des liens très directs entre 10 mécanis
puis ce qu'annonce le gouvernement le
jour même ou le surlendemain devant
cette avalanche de critiques François
Legault explique que c'est la fonction
publique qui a embauché la firmeckenzie
un contrat de plus de 6 millions de
dollars accordés sans appel d'offres ici
Pascal point Radio-Canada à Québec